heute kennt ihr das gefühl wenn die
person die euch gegenüber sitzt sieht
und ihr euch denkt die hat irgendwas
ausgelegt dass etwas im busch wurde aber
kinder selbst das gefühl wenn ihr
irgendwas verbotenes gemacht hatten
möchte danach schuldig fühlt genau das
testen heute denn wir sind heute wieder
auf test.de immer wieder in einem quiz
was heißt mal wieder seit ungefähr einem
jahr mal wieder so funktioniert es
natürlich nicht ich will sagen warum mal
wieder keinen sinn macht und in der
erklärung benutze ich dann mal wieder
sehr gut auf jeden fall leute wir sind
auf test.de und wir machen ein quiz das
heißt wie unschuldig bis tor
nun sitzt andere würde sagen das heißt
mit sky aber ich sage es jetzt losgeht
und wir legen direkt los mit frage
nummer eins leute beantwortete fragen
wir für euch mit dann finden wir heute
gemeinsam raus wie ich schuldig hier
alles inklusive fahrt natürlich einiges
über dinge die ich gemacht hat eventuell
verboten sind also lohnt sich mehr dran
zu bleiben was hast du schon mal etwas
gestohlen
leute was meint ihr was gestohlen safety
auf jeden fall die einzige sache an die
ich mich persönlich erinnere war damals
auf dem jahr mal reißt ein richtiger
gangster also nicht so tag live pipapo
so ein richtiger gangster bewaffnet mit
4 durch die straßen gelaufen und wenn
irgendeiner gesagt hat egal denn
bobbycars nicht das neueste modell dann
hab ich ja ja ja
aber ohne wird bei uns und da gab es
diese runden neulings kentucky
diese kriege ltte sind also bunt
irgendwie müssen so geregelte zucker
dinge die ihm heute nach außen gehen ja
die dinge habe ich gesehen und da habe
ich geschaut wieviel geld habe ich dabei
und werde ich gar kein geld dabei oder
ich hatte nicht genug geld dabei und ich
dachte mir ich brauche dieses ding und
dann bin ich hingegangen umgeschaut
ich hätte so einen muffensausen euch nie
was geklaut doch davor da hab ich nen
scheiß genommen hast du dir von deinen
geschwistern schon mal etwas genauer
ohne sie zu fragen hast du schon mal das
handy einer anderen person zu früher als
ich habe letztens das handy von einem
kollegen gekommen und hab es einfach ins
wasser geschmissen habe sein handy
genommen und vor seinen augen über
nämlich am see genommen und ins wasser
geschmissen haben galaxy s siemens
wasserdicht ist nix da öfter als einmal
am tag safe oder was anderes behauptet
ist liegt hast du schon mal etwas
wertvolles zerstört doch habe ich
natürlich leute dümmsten moment meines
lebens
ich habe einfach mal über ein laptop von
mirko darüber geschüttet ich hatte den
laptop ihre stehen daneben die flasche
cola und weil ich einfach ein bisschen
gestört bin habe ich die kurve lässt
dass du über deine freunde
über meine guten freunde für seine
wirklich guten freunde meine wirklich
guten freunden lässt sich nicht hast du
schon mal zu viel getrunken gemeint ist
alkohol hast du dich schon mal aus dem
haus geschlichen obwohl es nicht
durftest gast habe ich mich als kind nie
getraut wollt ich habe mich nie getraut
mich aus dem haus zu schleichen über die
story schon allein gehört meine eltern
nicht etwas das ich springe aus dem
fenster dritter stock mich nicht aber
das habe ich nie gemacht hast du schon
mal ohne erlaubnis ein peinliches foto
von einem freund verschickt da muss ja
so eine sache denken wir haben also eine
urlaubs clique mit der wir jedes jahr
urlaub fahren und da haben wir
irgendwann mal angefangen bilder von zu
machen während wir schlafen wir waren
irgendwie 2 luca und haben dann
angefangen fotos von max zu machen der
in dem moment geschlafen hat ja toll wie
sieht man aus wie man schläft und dann
haben wir entweder fix gemacht haben in
der gruppe um geschickt und fanden das
so witzig aber max mein bruder nicht
mehr freund ich glaube ich gesagt nicht
sollte also erstmals ich klein war gab
es ja noch nicht so was wie whatsapp
oder das wollte da konnte man nicht
viele bilder verschicken aber ich glaube
ich sagt nicht nein passt schon mal
etwas geholt - zu sagen bis auf jeden
fall ist schon mal eine fräulein
gespielt etwas unerlaubtes zu tun
ich riet ihr was denkt ihr von mir meine
freunde anstiften was unerlaubtes zu tun
zum beispiel zu schnell zu fahren drogen
zu konsumieren
hast du schon mal bei dem alter gelogen
ein vorteil zu haben ja damals
gefälschten schülerausweis hast du schon
gesagt wir sind gut aus obwohl es nicht
stimmte das mache ich das mache ich
nicht leute das mache ich nämlich
wirklich nicht das finde ich auch so
komisch hast du schon mal bei einem test
in der schule geschummelt wichtige story
wichtige story leute dies schief gehen
kann wenn man leuten hilft hatte mein
ganzes leben lang noch nie in einem test
gespickt und da in der zehnten klasse
hatte ich so ein typ neben mir in so
einem test in wirtschaft von recht ich
dachte ja der typ eigentlich ganz cool
dabei wir keinen plan und fragt mich hat
die ganze zeit irgendwas ich hatte so
etwas noch nie gemacht hat man die
gespickt mit irgendwann geredet los und
ich gebe ihm halt über den tipp und dann
kommt der lehrer und weiß was passiert
ist dafür dass ich dem anderen helfen
wollte
bekomme ich nur sechs und er schreibt
die arbeit ganz normalen kriegt eins
folgen einfach wo ich wirklich gut war
einfach nur gedacht mensch nicht
gesetzlich abstoßend eine schokolade
oder anderen süßen kapitän schwester
geben willst ihn selbst essen dann der
schwester nicht sagen nein meine kleine
schwester der will ich das nicht antun
hast du schon mal bei einem einem
partnerprojekt der schule den partner
alleine arbeiten und trotzdem eine gute
note geben lassen passendes für fragen
leute besitzt du leute musik mit auch
wenn andere sagen dass sie stört ja ich
bin früher max durch die stadt gelaufen
ich weiß nicht ich bin so ein typ der
sehr musikalisch ist und ich habe immer
irgendwelche lieder oder irgendwelche
web sex im kopf und ich denke dann halt
so ja und dann liebe ich das so singen
pfeifen oder so repp lions rezitieren
durch die stadt und max liebster neben
der kasse er hat muss aufhören
rauf auf max urteil ich finde aber ich
schreckliche bruder aber weiter genau
steht über den magischen button findet
unschuldig oder schuldig ich glaub ich
na na da kommt etwas mehr zusammen aber
wahrscheinlich geht es etwas lustiger zu
stimmt ab passt auf dass es passt auch
dass es zu wild oder übermütig wird
ghana geben einfach so selbst den tipp
dass man jedes mal einfach komplett
ausrasten sollte in jedem leben 42
prozent spielt selber im durchschnitt 1
58 prozent der surfer die unschuld
selber heißt es in einer beschreibung
vor leute macht ihn gerne auch mal und
schreibt ihr ergebnis in die kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal haut rein macht